- I always like to wrap
things up with something
that could bring you some extra cheer.
This is what I'm liking.
So earlier this hour, we
met a teacher who taught
her second graders, how they
could make a real difference
in the community.
Now I wanna talk to you about
another passionate teacher.
This one is from right here in California
and she's helping students
express themselves
in her very first children's
book, let's say hi
to the author of Patty's Predicament.
Vicky who watches on K F R E TV.
Fresno. What's up
- Vicky.
- Hi. How are you today?
- I'm having a great day.
I hope you are as well.
Can you tell us about Patty's predicament?
- Well, Kelly, in my 23
years as a classroom teacher,
I found that there were
students that had avoidance
issues that weren't
getting their work done.
And as a teacher, my
expectations are high.
Those excuses are important
and I had empathy towards 'em
but we still need to get our work done.
And I learned very quickly
that what was happening
outside the classroom
affects what happens inside the classroom.
And so I was a seeker.
I went out and I, are they hungry?
Do they have friends? What's
going on after school?
Are they well?
And when I wrote this book,
this story is about a student
who's an amazing person in some ways.
And in other ways she
has avoidance issues.
And so Mrs. Becker, the
classroom teacher tries to
help Patty solve this predicament.
- I love that.
That's so true.
My mom was a teacher and
it, and it's so true.
Like what happens outside
the classroom definitely
affects emotionally where they're at.
Like physically, if they're tired
like all those things come into play
but you say the book is
not just important for kids
but for teachers as well to
maybe recognize that, right?
- Oh, absolutely.
That's why really.
That's why I wrote the
book when the pandemic hit
and I've always mentored
new teachers and it's like
oh my goodness, who's
gonna teach these teachers.
They have to seek, they
have to break that code.
And my sweet husband's like write a book.
So I did.
So I, my book is really, I
want every new teacher to have
in their hand, just, you know, be a seeker
figure it out that
child should not be left
behind that child is so worthy
of your attention and your effort.
- Absolutely. Ah, thank you so much, Vicky
for being an amazing
teacher, not only to students
but to other teachers too, you know
that's a club and you can
all help each other feed
off of each other ideas.
It's very, it's very cool.
It's very
teachers are the most
innovative people on the planet.
Thank you so much for being a teacher.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
And that's not all, ma'am
our season long partner
pilot pen, makers of friction.
The go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson show.
Want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly, just
like you ma'am so they are
giving you a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(crowd cheering & clapping)
- Wow. How amazing thank you so much.
So unexpected.
(cheering and clapping)
It's an honor to have you on this show.
Thank you so much.